a Sunday breakfast made of paper grapes
made of marbles meat made of vegetables
a brain made of wool or even a whole
head made of food Zaara
Ellenberger is a visual storyteller
everything around her serves as a source
of inspiration and of materials too so
when she's out shopping near her studio
in Berlin she's also working
I love all materials of course but I've
been especially fond of fruit and
vegetables for a long time probably
because they're so very dim the colors
are so vivid there's always an element
of surprise because I don't know what
I'll get it's an organic material no
garnishes mafia this is the studio where
Zahra
Ellenberger tests the limits of
traditional graphic design her work is
featured in advertisements glossy
magazines and in galleries and is
anything but flat she describes herself
as a 3d illustrator combining techniques
from the realms of art graphic design
and photography her main interest lies
in meticulous craftsmanship
Ellenberger grew up in Munich where her
mother designed jewelry and her father
ran a hip restaurant
[Music]
my line shaft was busted my passion for
crafting things probably goes back to my
childhood I belong to the generation of
children who grew up without TV or at
least with less TV and without a
computer or the digital world so there
was enough time and space to make things
with whatever was around 400 mafia
degree so bastard on those to give eyes
at them and fat and best of all the
pantry and my father's restaurant was my
playground when I was around four or
five fundamental causes that awoke a
lifelong interest in food having human
awesome to talk to to Lima smitten
Ellenberger went on to study graphic
design in London then set up a jewelry
label with her boyfriend at the time but
she felt limited in her creativity so
she started sending her 3d designs to
magazines and got rave reviews
now her works feature on the covers of
leading publications all over the world
[Music]
[Music]
stop supply plans at night I think that
as soon as you touch things with your
hands and let your own energy flow into
them something different emerges that's
perhaps more human and not quite so
flawless that interests me more than the
perfect surface of a 2d computer monitor
Zahra Allah Megas approach can also be
applied to larger surfaces she regularly
creates stunning displays for the luxury
brand Hermes in Germany
she loves challenges and wants her work
to look good from all sides
she tends to collaborate with other
artists and artisans on larger projects
she worked with a Berlin carpenter to
create these oversized office supplies
for an Hermes display
Monica yellow thing my career actually
began with a big failure I got a job at
a design agency and they let me go after
three weeks I'd been assigned to
redesign an opera magazines and when the
creative director saw my result he said
it was unfortunately no better than the
original so I had to go heft on tour
finished an egg on and on but he did
something that was encouraging for my
future he said my portfolio looked more
like a box of magic tricks than a
traditional designers portfolio and that
I didn't have to worry I would make it
somewhere I am uphill and mostly made
kind of zog my hunger loss virtualize
Mia and she did today Zara
Ellenberger is one of Europe's most
successful illustrators and her
unmistakable style is in demand the
world over
[Music]